biggest cause of debt in this country
besides mortgages student debt because
there's no jobs out there for these
people who trusted their country to be
there for them they basically did that
exercise where you fall backwards and
your workmates catch you they jumped out
of the 40th floor window with that
student loan and America went that looks
like that hurt suck it up Caroline get a
job don't be a leech
would I advise a young person looking at
their senior year in high school to
become a freshman in college the year
after that's a damn good question how
long will it be until America fiscally
turns itself around to where the risk of
the investment on that student loan to
get a person through four years of
college will that person get a job we're
paying off that loan and getting a house
and affording a family will that be a
possibility in the present America it
doesn't look like it is when will that
turn around when will that get better
when will be okay for someone to go I'm
going to college I don't know I don't
get to push those rocks around but as it
is now there's a lot of really qualified
people who are doing jobs fathoms below
their ability level we are wasting
people's time who put considerable
amounts of energy time and their youth
into hitting those books when they
wanted to go off doing everything else
as a young person has wanted to do they
hit the books they did what they were
told they paid and paid and their
parents paid and they're not getting the
promise of America because those jobs
went away you know and the people who
could be in charge of the jobs that went
away went away so people who could be in
upper management there's an upper
manager but he's in Beijing he's in pnom
Penh he's in Bangkok those jobs went
away to police stockholders so it does
not matter how you shift the tax burden
around
that much there's no jobs in this
country there's just until major
industries come back you got what you
got and so you say good a job okay to
get a job you're way off to get three of
them I'll work at you know the hamburger
place until evening there's a great
story I'm sure it's kind of a folk tale
some guy told it to me there's a guy
goes into his building every day and he
sees the custodian morning morning same
guy in the green suit of the broom sees
him on the way out
one night the guy stays late and he's
working late
you know big deadline he leaves it like
1:00 in the morning he sees the same guy
in the security officers outfit the
janitor guy same building different
uniform it's like we got a new job he
goes no this is my other job the guy
goes down to the locker gets a dinner
break puts on the other uniform and
walks through the rooms he was sweeping
five hours before and that's where a lot
of Americans are at you have a country
that's undercutting itself for the cheap
quick buck they're after the fast hi
there after the grift rather than going
all-in on America the long-term goal and
investment if it were me I'd be going
like China does 500 years at a time I'd
be looking way up the road I'd be
looking up the road so far my eyes would
fall out of my head that's how much I
believe in America that's how much I
love America to where I want America
like Europe we're the village of Kate
yours your gift illis head explodes you
want to go to college go we need you we
need doctors because people grow up and
fall down and go boom
everyone's gonna need a doctor listen
let's have three doctors per floor of
every apartment building in this town
how about that is a good idea like that
is a good idea okay so let's make
college tuition either free or really
low and if you have a country full of
whip-crack smart people you have a
country the rest of the world will fear
they will not invade a country of
educate
people because we are so smart we'll
build a laser that will burn you the
enemy in your sleep before you eat you
can even mobilize your air force to kill
us we will kill you so fast because
we're so smart and we will have foreign
policy that will not piss you off to the
point to where you have to attack us the
world would be a better place and all
the war profiteers and the people who
make money on discontent robberies the
pillaging of economies in other
countries they'd be screwed and it'd be
the end of disaster capitalism and so
again it's always down to the education